[Musik]
sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder dem des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit
oder ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern wäldern
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
1944 geht der zweite weltkrieg schon ins
fünfte jahr
millionen stehen unter waffen
millionen schuften in fabriken
[Musik]
obwohl die alliierten mehr ressourcen
mehr reserven und mehr schlagkraft als
die achsenmächte haben ist ein ende des
krieges nicht absehbar
im gegenteil die blutigsten monate
stehen erst noch bevor
[Musik]
bis januar 1944 sind gut 1,9 millionen
soldaten der wehrmacht gefallen
doch im deutschen reich stehen noch
immer fast neuneinhalb millionen männer
unter waffen
anfang 1944 ist die rote armee weiter
auf dem vormarsch und befreit über 300
städte und dörfer die wehrmacht verfolgt
auf ihrem rückzug die strategie der
verbrannten erde
georgi wien agrar dorf hat an der
offensive teilgenommen
die deutschen waren auf dem rückzug sie
ließen motorräder mit beiwagen zurück
ein kamerad schlug mir vor dass er sich
in den beiwagen setzt und feuert und so
erschossen wir viele deutsche
am 17 januar durchbrechen sowjettruppen
den belagerungsring um leningrad und
vereinen sich mit verbündeten einheiten
im dorf roger die strategie der
deutschen vernichtung durch hunger hat
1,1 millionen stadtbewohner das leben
gekostet
bei lifting sc mit dem ende der
belagerung leningrads war der krieg für
die deutschen so gut wie gelaufen nach
dem rückzug von dort wurden sie immer
weiter in richtung westen zurückgedrängt
und bis nach berlin
am 27 januar wird die bahnstrecke moskau
leningrad befreit
die 872 tage andauernde belagerung ist
endgültig vorbei
[Musik]
anfang märz startet die rote armee eine
frühjahrsoffensive
mit ihren wendigen t 34 panzer treibt
sie die zahlenmäßig weit unterlegenen
wehrmachts truppen vor sich her und
testet sie mehrfach ein
am 15 april hat die rote armee den bug
den minister und den pott überquert die
deutschen müssen ihre stellungen hier
aufgeben
große teile der ukraine sind wieder in
sowjetischer hand
stalin plant einen entscheidenden schlag
und die deutschen besatzer aus der
sowjetunion zu vertreiben
[Musik]
boris 4 fun of war dabei
während der offensive merkten wir dass
irgend etwas im busch ist wir bekamen
plötzlich geschütze und mein zug wurde
um 16 soldaten verstärkt so dass wir
dann 28 waren die männer kamen aus den
zentralasiatischen republiken
zwischen juli 1943 und 1944 verliert
deutschland 41 divisionen in der
sowjetunion allein von märz bis mai 1944
fallen dort fast 382 tausend soldaten am
12 mai erklärt marschall georgi schukow
wir müssen so hart zuschlagen dass die
erde lebt
in germany die deutschen arten nicht was
für eine lawine da auf sie zurollte
die militärstrategen der roten armee
erwägen eine offensive im norden im
zentrum oder im süden der frontlinie
[Musik]
schließlich ziehen sie die streitkräfte
im zentrum zusammen
[Musik]
am 22 juni beginnt die großoffensive
operation back ration auf den tag genau
drei jahre nach dem überfall der
deutschen auf die sowjetunion
zunächst springen partisanen zigtausende
strategisch wichtige infrastruktur
punkte der wehrmacht in die luft dann
drücken 166 divisionen und 2700 panzer
gegen eine 1300 kilometer lange
frontlinie auf der anderen seite steht
die deutsche heeresgruppe mitte die aus
34 schlecht ausgerüsteten divisionen
bestätigt die deutschen hatten 600
flugzeuge die sowjets weit mehr als 5000
doch der wichtigste faktor war die
sowjetische artillerie mit über 25.000
geschützen auf deutscher seite waren es
nur noch 2500
der deutsche vorstoß nach außen ist
geschichte schon am ersten tag der
offensive werden die deutschen 16
kilometer weit zurückgedrängt nach einer
woche ist die deutsche front zerschlagen
und die truppen ziehen sich nach
weißrussland zurück ihre verluste sind
immens
38.000 gefallene
116.000 gefangenen
2000 panzer und 10.000 geschützt sind
verloren
[Musik]
wir kamen in völlig verlassene dörfer
die deutschen waren hals über kopf
geflüchtet sicher auch aus angst dass
sich die rotarmisten an ihnen rächen
würden für all die gräueltaten und
verbrechen die sie in der udssr begangen
hatten das hatte man ihnen sicher auch
so von seiten der führung aus vermittelt
in einer stadt machten wir dann halt am
hauptquartier des vierten chor
das hauptquartier war unterkellert
plötzlich hörten wir ein baby schreien
sie öffneten eine keller klappe und
seine mutter wie eine ihrer töchter
erwirkt hatte und das bei einem zweiten
kind auch tun wollte
[Musik]
huber sowie hielten sie davon ab und
brachten sie raus dann nahmen wir die
beiden überlebenden mädchen und die
mutter mit ins hauptquartier beruhigten
sie und gaben ihnen zu essen
natürlich hat die frau ihre schlimme tat
später bitter bereut
[Musik]
am 3 juli 1944 befreite die rote armee
die weißrussische hauptstadt minsk
die vierte armee der wehrmacht wird
eingekesselt
[Musik]
ende juli steht die rote armee nur noch
wenige hundert kilometer vom
führerhauptquartier wolfsschanze in
rastenburg entfernt
[Musik]
die heeresgruppe mitte ist so gut wie
zerschlagen
bis juli 1944 sind fast 25 millionen
wehrmachtsangehörige ums leben gekommen
in den letzten neun monaten bis
kriegsende werden noch weitere 2,5
millionen hinzukommen
ende juli 1944 nimmt die rote armee auch
die polnischen städte helm und lublin
ein
am stadtrand von lublin befreit die rote
armee erstmals ein vernichtungslager
majdanek
doris artjom of war dabei
als wir nahe der weichsel waren sahen
wir die freigelassenen sie liefen auf
uns zu sie kamen aus dem
konzentrationslager majdanek dann
erblickten wir die räume voller kleidung
brillen hautresten
und die gasöfen in denen die leichen
verbrannt wurden
[Musik]
am 25 juli steht die rote armee westlich
des flusses
burggraf thaddeus komorowski der
oberbefehlshaber der polnischen
heimatarmee telegrafierte nach london
wir sind jederzeit bereit für die
befreiung warschaus zu kämpfen
[Musik]
am ersten august ist es soweit die
heimat armee beginnt mit dem bewaffneten
aufstand in warschau und erobert teile
der besetzten stadt zurück
erstmals wieder polnische flaggen über
den dächern warschaus
doch die rote armee die auf der anderen
seite der wechsel steht greift nicht ein
die deutschen schlagen mit aller härte
zurück
weder die deutschen noch die polen
gingen davon aus dass die sowjets ihre
offensive für ganze fünf monate
unterbrechen würden fünf mal zwischen
diese entscheidung muss stalin höchst
persönlich getroffen haben must have
been taken by stellen ins auf die
aufständischen senden verzweifelte
telegramme
wir haben keine ausrüstung und keine
unterstützung mehr die soldaten und die
bewohner der hauptstadt blicken voller
hoffnung gen himmel aber nichts passiert
der aufstand scheitert die ss tötet
nicht nur aufständische sondern gezielt
auch zehntausende zivilisten dazu
springen abriss kommandos der deutschen
historische stätten und legen warschau
in schutt und asche
ss chef heinrich himmler der die völlige
zerstörung warschaus befohlen hatte
pollok täter gegenüber dass das
polnische problem für unsere kinder und
für alle die nach uns kommen ja schon
für uns kein großes problem mehr sein
wird
am 16 oktober marschiert die rote armee
in ostpreußen ein bis zur wolfsschanze
in rastenburg sind es nur noch 80
kilometer
1944 war entscheidend für die niederlage
der deutschen langsam zeigte sich dass
sie kriegsmüde wurden sie traten den
rückzug an
ende 1944 sind von der vermeintlich
unbesiegbaren wehrmacht nur noch
deutsche kriegsgefangene auf
sowjetischem territorium die rote armee
marschiert weiter gen westen und nimmt
kurs auf berlin
zwei wochen vor beginn der sowjetischen
großoffensive waren die westalliierten
im rahmen der operation overlord am 6
juni in der normandie gelandet stalins
ersehnte zweite front wird in frankreich
eröffnet die alliierten waren den
deutschen was waffen schiffe und
flugzeuge betraf weit überlegen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie es ein land
schaffen und sich dort festsetzen würden
war mehr als hoch ein scheitern hätte
allerdings katastrophale folgen
gehandelt jeder der an der planung und
vorbereitung der invasion beteiligt war
wusste was auf dem spiel stand
am 5 juni schreibt field marshall allen
brook dass operation overlord zum
schlimmsten desaster des ganzen krieges
werden könnte
us oberbefehlshaber dwight die
eisenhower weiß was auf dem spiel steht
er bereitet ein statement vor falls die
landung an den stränden der normandie
misslingt
unsere landungen haben nicht die von uns
erhoffte sichere stellung erbracht die
truppen die luftstreitkräfte und die
marine haben ihren dienst mit aller
tapferkeit und hingabe erfüllt wenn
jemand schuld für diesen vorstoß trägt
dann bin ich es ich allein er wird diese
reden halten müssen einen tag später am
5 juni gibt er den einsatzbefehl zu sich
selbst sagt er ich bete zu gott dass ich
weiß was ich tue
[Musik]
operation overlord ist die größte
landungsoperation der militärgeschichte
156.000 115 alliierte soldaten landen
mit ihren panzern und fahrzeugen an
einem insgesamt 80 kilometer breiten
küstenstreifen die idee der längste tag
hat begonnen
fast 12.000 alliierte flugzeuge
unterstützen den angriff der gegner am
himmel ist die dritte flotte der
deutschen luftwaffe die im kampfgebiet
nur noch über 169 einsatzfähige
jagdflugzeuge verfügt
für operation aktion die lande operation
der invasion stehen
6939 schiffe bereit
der britische marine kommandeur admiral
bertram ramsey koordiniert die überfahrt
der schiffe durch den minen verseuchten
unruhigen ärmelkanal sowie die landung
an den stark befestigten stränden der
normandie
einem abschnitt des atlantik weiß der
wehrmacht
[Musik]
als sich alle als wir aus liefen waren
mehr als 5000 schiffe unterwegs um die
invasion in der normandie möglich zu
machen was für ein anblick
es war heftig die see war den männern
war schlecht vor allem auch weil sie
hunger hatten
[Musik]
hoffmann erklärte uns an bord der
schiffe was das ziel der operation war
so schnell wie möglich an land zu gehen
dann in richtung kirche marschieren und
von dort weiter auf die straßen
[Musik]
um 6 uhr 30 morgens erstürmen die ersten
landung truppen omaha beach einen von
insgesamt fünf anvisierten
strandabschnitten in der normandie león
gt kämpft für ein freies frankreich
am 6 juni um 7 uhr 23 morgens erreichten
wir den strand zunächst sollten wir das
blockhaus einnehmen auf keinen fall
stehen bleiben im kampf musst du immer
ein bewegliches ziel sein hitler hält
den angriff für ein täuschungsmanöver
er rechnet damit dass die haupt in
version 3 100 kilometer weiter nördlich
stattfinden wird am pkw der engsten
stelle des ärmelkanals
zudem hält die deutsche wetter
aufklärung einen angriff am 6 juni für
unmöglich die deutschen besatzer werden
kalt erwischt
doch auch die alliierten verschätzen
sich sie gehen davon aus dass am omaha
beach nur 800 soldaten stationiert sind
meist ältere männer ohne kampf erfahrung
die landung truppen rechnen mit geringem
widerstand
das gegenteil ist der fall drei
bataillone der 352 division mit fast
1500 kampf kräftigen wehrmachtsoldaten
haben die stellungen vor kurzem
übernommen und leisten erbitterten
widerstand
alle sollten runter vom schiff und an
land stürmen wir kümmerten uns um die
toten und verletzten
am omaha beach fallen an diesem tag die
meisten alliierten soldaten am utah
beach mit
197 die wenigsten fast 23.000 schaffen
es hier an den strand
da wir sahen überall blitze und tote
bricht jemand rief montag vom strand
runter vom strand aber das musste mir
niemand sagen
ich wusste wo ich hin muss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein kamerad blickte mit irrsinnigem
gesichtsausdruck über seine schulter wo
teile seines armes hängende er wurde
voll an der schulter erwischt und
stierte auf die wunde
[Musik]
am abend des 6 juni sind 83.000 115
britische und kanadische und rund 73.000
us-soldaten an land am 19 juni werden
die ersten alliierten flugfelder in
betrieb genommen am 10 juni vereinen
sich die briten mit den us-truppen von
omaha beach am 13 juni schließen die us
einheiten von utah beach auf innerhalb
von vier wochen ist die zahl von
133.000 alliierten soldaten an der küste
auf 850.000 mann angewachsen hinzu
kommen 150.000 fahrzeuge und weit mehr
als eine halbe millionen tonnen
nachschub stalin telegrafierte an
churchill overlord ist ein quell der
freude für uns alle bis zum 25 juli
haben die alliierten eine million
450.000 mann und über 4000 panzer an
land gebracht
ddp
die anzahl alliierter truppen auf
europäischem boden war nach dem d day so
groß dass die deutsche kriegsmaschinerie
nicht mal ansatzweise eine chance gegen
sie hatte lag halb mittwoch ist
[Musik]
am 31 juli durchbrechen us-soldaten die
front bei orange generalfeldmarschall
von kluge will den rückzug antreten um
nicht eingekesselt zu werden doch hitler
versagt ihm diese bitte
[Musik]
bis zum 31 juli hat die wehrmacht 406
panzer und mehr als
127.000 soldaten verloren als
verstärkung kommen nur 10.000 78 mann
und 17 panzer der soldat johannes bonner
erinnert sich
die switch am 18 juli traten wir den
rückzug an sie gerieten in die
sogenannte verlässt tasche
über 100.000 deutsche soldaten sitzen im
kessel von verlässt gegen die alliierten
übermacht von
350.000 soldaten haben die ausgezehrten
wer mass verbände keine chance
10.000 soldaten sind an der verlässt
asche gefahren
manchmal ging die im wahrsten sinn des
wortes über leichen
gehen wir durch wollten ihre taschen auf
der suche nach zigaretten oder etwas
erst waren wir hatten ja seit zwei
wochen nichts mehr gegessen
[Musik]
die zwölfte ss panzerdivision
hitlerjugend leistet erbitterten
widerstand und hält den kessel bis zum
21 august offen
etwa 30.000 deutsche soldaten können
viele
50.000 werden getötet verwundet oder
gefangen genommen
[Musik]
nach dem sieg in fall es ist der weg für
die westalliierten nach paris frei
diese überlassen charles de gaulle den
vortritt am 26 august zieht der
französische general triumphierend über
die champs élysées erst drei tage später
folgt dort eine us parade
[Applaus]
wer sich mit den besatzern eingelassen
hat wird verprügelt
gedemütigt und kahl geschoren
[Applaus]
die franzosen feiern ihre befreiung von
den nazis
[Applaus]
dies sah so aus als hätten sie
frankreich befreit
[Applaus]
aber jeder weiß dass paris sich nicht
selbst befreit hat es war frei weil
riesige us-truppen verbände vor den
toren der stadt standen
wieder auferstanden in paris begleitet
von der macht
am 10 september erreichen us-truppen den
stadtrand von aachen die einnahme der
kaiserstadt steht bevor
doch trotz der erdrückenden us übermacht
denkt hitler nicht ans aufgeben
[Musik]
adolf hitler hatte die wahnhafte
vorstellung dass er mit 200.000
deutschen soldaten eine über 100
kilometer breite front durchbrechen
könnte um dann eine million us soldaten
zu überrollen
am 17 september starten die alliierten
die operation market garden die bis
dahin größte luft lande operation der
geschichte damit wollen sie den
deutschen westwall umgehen
market garden market garden bestand aus
zwei operationen bei market wurden
truppen aus der luft hinter einigen
brücken abgesetzt haben wir eine land
offensive und beide truppen sollten sich
dann vereinigen eigentlich ein guter
plan
die us-luftstreitkräfte sind zunächst
erfolgreich und erobern brücken im
holländischen eindhoven und in dem wegen
sex
app doch dann landete die erste
alliierte luftlande armee quasi direkt
auf einer deutschen ss panzerdivision
es folgt die schlacht von arnheim
wir waren 20 fallschirmjäger 10 in jeder
reihe ich saß gerade ein magazin und
fragte mich was uns auf der anderen
seite der front erwarten würde dann
rotes licht aufstehen parken fest grünes
licht freigabe und los
die beiden ss panzerdivision anlagen ein
paar kilometer voran
heinemann wir hatten sie überrascht aber
ihre antwort kam prompt
der versuch die rheinbrücke bei arnheim
einzunehmen misslingt operation market
garden ist gescheitert
ein angriff folgte auf den anderen
dann starb direkt neben mir als er starb
spritzt er sein blut auf mich
und dann sagte ein deutscher offizier in
bestem englisch wenn sie nicht
rauskommen schieße ich sie raus also
ging ich raus
[Musik]
dennoch die wehrmacht wird an allen
fronten zurückgedrängt hitler holt zum
gegenschlag aus
am morgen des 16 dezember sicher nur
vier zum teil unerfahrene usd visionen
die 100 kilometer lange frontlinie sie
ahnen nicht dass hitler einen
überraschungsangriff plant er will mit
drei armeen durch die ardennen brechen
und anschließend brüssel und antwerpen
einnehmen um den nachschub der
alliierten abzuschneiden die
ardennenoffensive
deckname wacht am rhein beginnt
[Musik]
wir waren in einem gehöft in der nähe
von bastos
ich lag neben einem kumpel als sie
plötzlich so ein pfeifen dürfen und
irgendetwas genau zwischen uns krachte
es war eine 88 jahre aber sie
detonierten nicht ich sagte zu ihm rüber
und sagte scheiße und die antwortete
habe ich in meiner hose
eisenhower verlegt truppen in die
ardennen und die deutsche gegenoffensive
zu vereiteln
die dritte armee nach norden schwenken
eine entscheidung die zusammenhängende
führte fakt ist dass die deutschen in
den ardennen massiv unter druck gerieten
wir gehörten zu einer der divisionen die
patton hoch geschickt hatte sie dachten
dass wir uns an irgendwelchen häusern
raus lassen würden damit wir uns
aufwärmen konnten
aber sie setzen uns irgendwo mitten im
wald ab
es war eisig bis dahin hatte ich noch
nie erwachsene männer vor kälte weinen
sehen
[Musik]
vermutlich hätte kein anderer general im
westen als patton sein heer mit erfolg
eine 90 grad kehre machen lassen um die
männer bei bastogne zu retten ist ein
betrieb seine truppen an sie kamen
schnell ans ziel und das war eine
beeindruckende strategische leistung
in den weihnachtstagen klagte das wetter
auf und die alliierten luftstreitkräfte
konnten endlich eingreifen
trotz harter kämpfe sind die alliierten
letztendlich an material und männern
überlegen
und obwohl die deutschen anfängliche
geländegewinne gemacht hatten wird die
deutsche offensive schon nach wenigen
wochen niedergekämpft am 16 januar ist
die alte frontlinie schließlich wieder
hergestellt
[Musik]
denn die ardennen schlacht hat der
panzer mit der wehrmacht endgültig das
genick gebrochen war markt zudem
ermöglichte sie der sowjetunion den
schnellen vormarsch fast bis nach berlin
innerhalb von zwei wochen
19.000 soldaten der fünften us heeres
gruppe kommen bei der ardennen schlacht
ums leben mehr als 21.000 werden
gefangen genommen oder vermisst doch im
januar und februar 1945 schicken die usa
weitere truppen 7 komplett ausgerüstete
divisionen landen in europa drei davon
sind panzerdivisionen die deutschen
verluste wiegen schwer
68.000 gefallene vermisste und gefangene
sowie
554 panzer und 800 flugzeuge können
nicht mehr aufgefüllt werden
dann wurden wir an den rhein verlegt
werden keine ahnung warum vermuteten
aber dass wir ins deutsche kern land
eindringen würden wir wussten nur dass
deutschland auf der anderen seite des
flusses lag also pinkelten wir alle ins
wasser das sollte glück bringen
[Musik]
allein im januar 1945 fallen 451 1742
wehrmachtsoldaten mehr als auf us seite
während des ganzen krieges um kommen
werden
am 31 januar überquerten sowjetische
truppen an der ostfront die oder
bereits am zwölften januar 1945 startet
die rote armee eine großangelegte
offensive die wechsel oder operation am
17 januar fällt warschau am achtzehnten
krakau und budapest binnen zwei wochen
haben die sowjetischen truppen 400
kilometer geländegewinn gemacht ende
januar stehen sie nur noch 80 kilometer
vor berlin dort pausieren sie
stalin hat seine einheiten unterwegs gut
verteilt lettland estland litauen polen
ungarn die tschechoslowakei bulgarien
rumänien und ostdeutschland sowie
jugoslawien sind jetzt unter
sowjetischem einfluss am 16 april soll
der angriff auf berlin beginnen
[Musik]
ende februar zieht hitler mit seinem
engsten stab in den sogenannten
führerbunker unter der reichskanzlei
tausende deutsche soldaten und
zivilisten die nicht mehr kämpfen wollen
werden von improvisierten stand
gerichten zum tode verurteilt
[Musik]
noch in den letzten kriegstagen sagte
man den deutschen der eine weiße fahne
hisst wird erschossen
am 16 april beginnt die schlacht um
berlin allein am ersten tag feuernacht
1983 sowjetische artilleriegeschütze
eine million
236.000 granaten ab die berühmten stalin
orgeln am 25 april vereinen sich schubs
und conny us truppen bei potsdam berlin
ist eingeschlossen
davis hat in 2,3 millionen soldaten und
über 6.000 panzer des sowjet standen nur
850.000 deutsche soldaten mit 1500
tänzern gegenüber
am 27 april kontrollieren die deutschen
nur noch einen kleinen teil berlins
einen tag später bläst die rote armee
zum sturm auf den reichstag
[Musik]
dann änderte sich das stadtbild in
berlin alles war weiß weiße tücher
hängen aus den fenstern und von den
balkonen überall bettlaken
kissenbezüge alles möglich die berliner
legten bereitwillig ihre waffen nieder
und kapituliert berlins kindes frauen
und kinder verließen ihre wohnungen und
gingen auf die straße
als regisseur ist
[Musik]
adolf hitler diktiert sein testament am
30 april lässt er seinen schäferhund
vergiften und begeht anschließend
gemeinsam mit eva braun selbstmord
einige stunden später hessen soldaten
aus joops dritte armee die rote fahne
auf dem reichstag
damit will die erreichten berlin und
wurden direkt nach süden zum reichstag
geleitet
[Musik]
sie wollten aufs dach und das rote
banner des siegels ist
berlin berlin war der hauptgewinn die
besetzung der gegnerischen hauptstadt
hat eine immense psychologische
bedeutung
niemand wusste was wir tun sollen
[Musik]
jorch angeschrien lachten fielen sich in
die arme was ist passiert
[Musik]
musik genie krieges zu ende und sie alle
freuten sich verbrüderten sich küssten
und umarmten sich wir feierten bis in
den abend
[Musik]
nazi deutschland ist besiegt doch im
pazifik herrscht weiter krieg
fünfzehnter juni 1944 ein knappes jahr
vor kriegsende während die alliierten
sich von den stränden der normandie ins
inland vorkämpfen landen 2 usd visionen
auf der marianen inseln zypern
in der schlacht um die 190
quadratkilometer große insel sterben
3426 amerikaner und rund 24.000 japaner
unter ihnen viele zivilisten
wir lagen vor japan und sahen wie
zivilisten von den klippen sprang sie
begingen selbstmord mit ihren kindern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 19 juni liefern sich japan und die
usa zudem eine heftige schlacht in der
philippinen see es ist die größte träger
schlacht des pazifiks
[Musik]
japan verliert drei flugzeugträger und
476 kampfflugzeuge die usa verzeichnen
lediglich 123 zerstörten flugzeuge
general macarthur zurück ins geschehen
im pazifikkrieg bei einem treffen in san
francisco treffen sich die us admiral
akin niemitz und spleens um die weitere
strategie im pazifikkrieg festzulegen
sie einigen sich auf okinawa als
hauptangriffsziel wollen jedoch um ihre
luftüberlegenheit herzustellen auch die
nahe gelegene insel iwo jima einnehmen
[Musik]
kaiser zu sterben
wir holten die truppen nach iwo jima
tausende von australischen englischen
und amerikanischen schiffen gingen
direkt vor dem sony battenberg vor anker
etwa ein halbes jahr zuvor hatte
generalmajor tariq uri baschi seinen
21.000 soldaten befohlen die insel in
eine uneinnehmbare festung zu verwandeln
[Musik]
sie hatten ein über 30 kilometer langes
tunnelsystem mit verschiedenen geschütz
stellungen installiert
thema war die erste insel und die erste
schlacht bei der die japaner den usa
mehr schaden zufügten als sie selbst
erlitten
am 6 august 1945 nimmt ein b 29 bomber
kurs auf hiroshima mit an bord die rund
drei tonnen schwere atombombe little boy
nach dem abwurf detoniert sie in 5 175
metern höhe
im epizentrum der explosion herrschen
temperaturen von mehreren millionen grad
celsius
[Musik]
die vernichtungskraft der bombe ist so
groß dass die roscheba buchstäblich dem
erdboden gleichgemacht wird
63 prozent aller gebäude werden komplett
zerstört
140.000 menschen sterben sofort durch
die folgen der radioaktiven verstrahlung
sind es am ende
200.000
[Musik]
kenji kitagawa war elf als die
apokalypse über hiroshima hereinbrach
es gab einen weißen blitz ich habe dann
einen riesenkrach ein gigantisch lautes
klirren
das schulgebäude wurde vollkommen
zerstört
und ich wurde unter den trümmern
begraben
ich konnte die stimmen meiner freunde
hören und einige lebten noch in den
trümmern sie schrien verzweifelt mama
papa es tut so weh hilfe
[Musik]
stani reicht auch eine rolle dass eine
viele leute trieben im fluss in dem sie
gesprungen waren um ihre verbrennungen
zu kühlen
es war ein höllen strom voller menschen
die vor der hitze des feuers flohen und
um hilfe riefen
[Musik]
drei tage nach hiroshima wird eine
zweite atombombe über nagasaki
abgeworfen
einen tag zuvor marschierte die rote
armee nach absprache mit den alliierten
in der mandschurei als
die rote armee die japaner in der
mandschurei angriff war es vorbei
innerhalb einer woche töteten die
sowjets 82.000 japanische soldaten und
verwundeten um die 200.000
jede ok qureshi kämpfte damals auf
seiten der japaner
am morgen stieg schwarzer rauch auf
[Applaus]
wir wurden angegriffen
unsere unterkunft wurde in die luft
gesprengt
panzer rollten auf uns zu
granaten flogen
morgens waren wir 190 männer
mittags klebten davon nur noch 50
alle anderen starben im kampf
eine woche nach dem angriff der
sowjetischen truppen hören die japaner
zum ersten mal die stimme ihres kaisers
im radio
wir haben die regierung angewiesen den
regierungen der usa großbritanniens
chinas und der sowjetunion mitzuteilen
dass unser reich die bedingungen ihrer
gemeinsamen erklärung akzeptiert
am 2 september 1945 unterzeichnet japans
aussenminister skigebiets mamoru die
bedingungslose kapitulation auf dem us
schlachtschiff us visum für die usa
unterzeichnet general macarthur hinter
ihm ausgezehrt von japanischer
kriegsgefangenschaft general in rheydt
und
die zeremonie dauert 23 minuten
die menschen morgen weiter das sterben
in der welt dauert an doch zumindest
dieser krieg ist geschichte
in manchen gegenden wurden große teile
der bevölkerung ausgelöscht gemeinden
wurden zerstört kulturelle identitäten
und traditionen vernichtet bis zum
heutigen tag haben sie viele von ihnen
nicht davon erholt
millionen von menschen starben alleine
sechs millionen juden während des
holocausts
die menschen die den horror des zweiten
weltkriegs überlebten haben sich
aufgerafft
durchgekämpft gelitten verdrängt und
machten irgendwie weiter sie kehrten
zurück in ihren alltag wenn es ihn noch
gab doch den krieg hat niemand von ihnen
vergessen viele haben eine familie
freunde oder dinge an denen sie sich
erfreuen können andere haben nie
aufgehört zu trauern sie alle haben die
hölle auf erden überlebt seither hat es
viele andere kriege gegeben wann lernen
die menschen den frieden zu beschützen
[Musik]